hi recheck nation
Greg John we're gonna watch the honest
trailer for everyone's Anderson movie
I think there's eight of them one of our
page from a war tears if you call any
video you guys requests whether it be
discussion or reaction we must
definitely do put up on the youtubes
this is requested by none other than
movie reviewer Andrew Hayes guys make
sure go check out his channel Wes
Anderson I think I've seen four or five
of his movies I definitely haven't seen
all of them haven't seen Darjeeling
Limited habits fantastic mister haven't
seen that one in life aquatic but I
think I've seen all the other ones let's
do this I'm surprised so many requested
or not show see the whimsical new
animated features before you see the
whimsical it before you see the
whimsical new you know what the epic was
just isn't right fit for Wes Anderson
get anyone here do a good Alec Baldwin
hello
close enough take it away Baldy before
you see the whimsical new animated
feature from your baristas favorite
director revisit
[Music]
why are they laughing every movie I mean
film every was Anderson Phil savage
forth and Tallyho with director Wes
Anderson who style is so specific he's
basically his own genre more symmetrical
shots than you can shake an art
department into a quirky indoor tent and
more whimsy than a lovestruck Cub Scout
dancing in his underwear to a lakeside
record player honestly after eight
movies I'm not sure if I made that shot
up or not meet a Wes Anderson
protagonist watch him deal with a
strained parental relationship I think
he's onto us of course but with the help
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
feature including a tale of two
disaffected friends the cleaning woman
that one of them loves and a
meticulously planned robbery that goes
wrong a tale of this disaffected student
is disaffected older friends the teacher
both of them love and a meticulously
planned revenge lot that goes wrong
[Laughter]
and a meticulously different robbery
goes wrong but these noodles affected
kids more in love with each other and
the meticulously planned escape that
goes along and it don't matter that much
that goes on it sounds repetitive but
trust me they're just the most charming
little things Leslie the adorable
looking Isle of Dogs revisit the
director who could only be described as
Wes Anderson
well fluent an entire generation of
indie filmmakers and an even larger
generation of pale hipsters who hate
their parents you just don't get me dad
I was born in the wrong decade oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
shots of writing shows a typewritten
letters yeah with pens
[Music]
we'll start with Baga says chicken house
number one it's 25 inches of reinforced
granite masonry I'd like to pitch camp
here about 1,600 characters running away
suddenly yeah they're gonna be the best
yeah yeah yeah base punches characters
with dead parents you should have been a
dentist you know my father died at
seven-and-a-half my father was murdered
Willem Dafoe dead animals Willem Dafoe
bleh
I'm glad they brought two dead animals
there's a lot of that tiny telephones
anjelica huston on an Internet telephone
foreigners classic rock songs
[Music]
oil paintings classic rocks characters
reading books uniforms graveyards jason
schwartzman smoking moving vehicles
relationships oh yeah oh yeah - reel
tape recorder tiny motorcycles you know
we gave him crap for repeating yourself
but the last thing anyone wants is a
desaturated shaky-cam cgi fest out of
him just a movie about the drama club at
Hogwarts
do you love puppies then click the link
on the left because we got the cast of
Pacific Rim to play with puppies
uprising our made-up names then I am
spider-man remind me why do I keep
raiding all these weapons o ye reduce
hey man that was a that was a pretty
brilliant breakdown of every Wes
Anderson movie that is his style man
that film is cool so I would love for
them to do more of every day because
there's a lot of huge directors who
don't actually have a large filmography
just like you do spill British film
Ridley Scott you're like a Tarantino one
Tarantino only has like eight films - a
PT n or CT Anderson venture or Jordan
you get a lot of directors for this but
yeah that is so true I mean there's
obviously things that I've always
noticed that are similar in all the Wes
Anderson films like the zooms the whip
has the symmetry this has no colors the
symmetrical overhead shot the shots of
riding the profile shots the characters
running away suddenly the dead animals
one is something I have noticed actually
that he does randomly throw in and I
don't ever really know the usage of it
like what is the purpose exactly
sometimes it seems to be poor like
comedic purpose like in grand Budapest
hotel when will him to foe just throws
the cat out the window and kills it
well that just says something about that
character - yeah it depends on the
instance in which movie but it is an odd
motif for sure I don't really understand
his purpose for using it all the time
but the oil paintings are like that that
is one of their best sorry because I
would out for a while but you're like
yeah that's true they do I just love the
combinations of all these motifs as they
keep coming back
I mean Wes Anderson's style kind of
reminds me like of a quirky or hybrid of
life Scorsese meets Paul Thomas Anderson
like with the whip pans the zooms the
wide framing the symmetry and where the
music plays a heavier part and it's like
a court here Paul Thomas Anderson but
has this rhythm of Scorsese in certain
ways I do love a Wes Anderson film
though like I haven't seen all of them
but every time I watch them there was
this dark like I love the intro off the
beginning of it he'll make you kind of
happy it'll make you kind of sad because
there's this life II think also the dead
bear it's one oh so true yeah and just
seeing them all it's like I pick these
things up individually over time it's
seeing them all here yeah wow it really
does have a very engrained style yeah
but it seems to work super well and the
thing is - that's interesting about wes
anderson is while these things of low
wes anderson tropes can be repetitive he
kind of gets better like grand budapest
hotel to me is probably his best film
that's my favorite of his movie and it
has all the Wes Anderson things though
well cuz it's not like this is
repetitive
this is his best one yeah yeah and I
feel like what keeps things fresh is
just the fact that he really goes for
different settings different characters
different themes each time even though
he is using a lot of the same people a
lot of the same approaches stylistically
each story is like so specifically yeah
its own story the he's able to get by
with it not becoming stale over time and
I love that not only did I get a huge
laugh out of this yeah there's like a
film school lesson this could actually
open up a new door for what honest
trailers could be yeah cuz they've been
mixing up they've been they've revamping
their movie fights and they've added
another little revamp again on movie
fights when they come back so this could
be a new kind of honest trailer to that
I think would be very much appreciated
at least for like these film school
dudes so yeah I really like this one a
lot
Andrew Hayes thank you so much for
recommending this man this was a funny
ass video and I really learned a lot of
dude Andrew if you guys haven't seen
Andrew Hayes's movie channel this dude
has a lot of enthusiasm a lot of
enthusiasm he's a funny guy and he hates
how people talk about his height he's
four foot five in case anyone wanted oh
no no because he told us sooner that the
most annoying question he gets asked is
are you a [ __ ]
and I want everyone to know right here
right now a [ __ ] is not a kind word be
a little person andrew is borderline
there but he is not just made the cut
just made the cut of a solid five feet
but all that extra height one two went
to what Oh actually it's kind of a
Medicaid kind of they've tried getting
it removed or at least making it more
reasonable sign that they don't have the
proper technology he could either get a
sex operation transgender switch or he
can just you know keep it well he can
just wear one of those harnesses that
keeps you from anything right now it's
causing him a lot of back pain
but hey Andrew I want you to know that
with great power and what you have comes
limited responsibility really good
notified every time when our biz is up
Thank You screen junkies for this
awesome video man I hope you do more of
these and check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions over there
as well as music videos weekly Q&A is
would love to have you